queridos amigos amigas tenemos una muy
mala noticia que contaros el yihadismo
está resurgiendo
O al menos eso es lo que ya están
alertando muchos expertos tanto en
Europa como en Estados Unidos la gran
mayoría de analistas aseguran que el
fenómeno está experimentando un nuevo
auge la razón seguro que ya os la podéis
imaginar 3 2s 1 Exacto hablamos de la
situación al rojo vivoo en la que se
encuentran Israel y Palestina o mejor
dicho Jamás pero es que acaso el
terrorismo jihadista había desapare
decido pues no nada más lejos de la
realidad si sois fieles seguidores de
visual politic recordaréis que en
lugares como Pakistán Afganistán
Uzbekistán los ataques están a la orden
del día y eso por no hablar de África el
sahel está infestado de terroristas
jihadistas Mali burkina faso Niger de
hecho boko Haram uno de los grupos
terroristas de yihadismo global más
conocidos está en Nigeria pero es que
incluso en China tienen algunos
problemas con este tema pero un momento
Entonces dónde decimos que está
resurgiendo exactamente pues
especialmente en Europa de hecho desde
el atentado de jamá a Israel y la
contraofensiva de Israel nos hemos
encontrado con noticias como estas poca
broma Francia eleva la alerta por
atentado tras el asesinato de un
profesor a manos de un islamista al
norte del país alerta en Italia se
refuerza la vigilancia en lugares
relacionados con la comunidad judía
Suecia eleva el nivel de alerta
terrorista tras las quemas del Corán
Dinamarca y Suecia han reforzado los
controles fronterizos porque temen
ataques de amenazas altas amigos en
Europa ya conocimos lo que fue sufrir un
atentado jihadista cada dos por tres
hace no más de 10 años al final el
fenómeno fue perdiendo cada vez más
fuerza hasta que la pandemia lo aplano
sin embargo esta vez puede ser diferente
y es que los analistas ya están
alertando de las nuevas formas que está
adoptando el terrorismo yihadista
Durante los últimos años formas aún más
escurridizas y con mayor capacidad de
éxito que las que utilizaba en el pasado
y precisamente por eso en visual politic
nos hemos hecho unas cuantas preguntas
Cómo logró Europa combatir la ola de
yihadismo que la soló hace tan solo unos
pocos años Estamos realmente frente a
una nueva oleada de terrorismo jihadista
en el viejo continente Por qué las
nuevas formas de yihadismo pueden
suponer un mayor riesgo para Europa que
las anteriores Pues bien hoy vamos a
responder a todas estas preguntas pero
para hacerlo primero tenemos que echar
la vista atrás
Comencemos Europa frente al
terror sabíais que en Europa el
terrorismo jihadista pilló a casi todos
por sorpresa el viejo continente estaba
acostumbrado a otro tipo de terrorismo a
uno de corte más nacionalista y político
Como por ejemplo el de eta en España o
el de Lira en Reino Unido sin embargo lo
cierto Es que la sorpresa europea no
estaba justificada en absoluto Y es que
veréis algunos combatientes jihadistas
ya comenzaron a penetrar el viejo
continente en los años 80 y No tardaron
demasiado en comenzar a extender las
redes de grupos más grandes como el
grupo islamista argelino o la propia
alcaeda fue así de hecho como Europa
comenzó a convertirse en un importante
nido
yihadista en un primer momento aquellas
redes lideradas principalmente por
alcaeda estaban organizadas de manera
jerárquica sin embargo después de los
atentados del 11s en Nueva York Osama
Bin Laden tomó la decisión de cambiar
por completo aquella estructura ante la
estrategia antiterrorista de Estados
Unidos que buscaba acabar con Los
líderes de la organización y del
yihadismo global las redes se
descentralizar Pero por qué pues muy
simple si se acababa con Bin Laden y al
resto de los cabecillas el yihadismo
global podría seguir funcionando sin
problema además Sería mucho muchísimo
más difícil de rastrear y contrarrestar
de esta forma Europa experimentó un
importante aumento de operaciones
antiterroristas que desarticularon
algunas células por ejemplo en enero de
2003 en Italia se desarticularon dos
pequeñas células yihadistas y en ese
mismo año en España tuvo lugar la famosa
operación lago en varios puntos de
Cataluña lo que llevó a la
desarticulación de una célula argelina
de tamaño mediano Sin embargo a medida
que se fue implementando la estrategia
de la descentralización todo se hizo
mucho más
difícil nada prepara Europa para lo que
estaba por llegar el 11 de marzo de 2004
una célula jihadista atentó en la
capital de España Madrid con 10 bombas
plantadas en diferentes tramos del
transporte público el ataque se saldó
con 193 fallecidos y más de 2000 heridos
fue el segundo ataque terrorista más
grande de toda la historia del
continente como os podéis imaginar esto
supuso todo un punto de inflexión en
Cómo la vieja Europa percibía el
terrorismo jihadista entonces
lógicamente la preocupación por esta
cuestión alcanzó niveles históricos
niveles que siguieron creciendo tras el
atentado en el metro de Londres al año
siguiente en 2005 un atentado que acabó
con otras 50 vidas y que provocó unos
700 heridos desde entonces amigos Europa
se mantuvo en un elevadísimo nivel de
alerta el viejo continente sufrió
algunos atentados menores y desbarató a
algunos mayores como el que 14
jihadistas vinculados al caeda tenían
planeado en el metro de Barcelona en
enero de 2008 sin embargo pese a todo en
2014 nos encontraríamos con una noticia
que llevaría la actividad jihadista en
Europa a niveles sin igual fijaos
Rebeldes del Isis declaran el estado
islámico en iraq y Siria en efecto el
Isis declaró el estado islámico y el
yihadismo global llegó a su punto álgido
el terrorismo jihadista se expandió por
todo el planeta y en Europa pegó
especialmente fuerte comenzó así la
primera oleada jihadista que como tal ha
experimentado el viejo
continente así que queridos amigos los
atentados en los países de la Unión
Europea se dispararon y con ellos las
víctimas mortales 347 solo entre 2015 y
2017 86 de ellas únicamente en el brutal
atentado de niiza de 2016 y no se trata
solo de las víctimas poco a poco estos
ataques fueron alimentando una sensación
de miedo generalizada no obstante y por
fortuna entre el progresivo
debilitamiento del Isis a partir del
2017 y los esfuerzos de los gobiernos
europeos La amenaza jihadista en Europa
comenzó a caer fuertemente para que os
hagáis una idea en 2022 apenas tuvieron
lugar seis atentados sin embargo esperad
un momento porque el atentado de jamás
contra Israel y la consecuente respuesta
israelí ha llevado la tensión en la
comunidad musulmana mundial al máximo
por ejemplo el exlíder de jamá caled
mesal llegó a protagonizar un anuncio
que muchos analistas interpretaron como
una llamada a la jihad global fijaos a
todos los eruditos que enseñan la yihad
por la causa de Dios y que predican a
los combatientes y a los mártires a
todos los que enseñan y aprenden Este es
un momento de aplicación de las teorías
para que las palabras no sean solo
palabras precisamente por eso tanto los
gobiernos de Europa como el de Estados
Unidos han alertado de un posible nuevo
aumento del terrorismo yihadista pero es
realmente esto un llamamiento a la jihad
global no se supone que quienes hacían
este tipo de cosas eran organizaciones
como alcaeda o el Isis Pues bien
veámoslo
la jihad global
resurge el 7 de octubre de 2023 jamás
perpetró uno de los ataques terroristas
as más sangrientos de la historia de
Israel más de 100 asesinados entre ellos
niños mujeres y ancianos las imágenes
impactaron al mundo entero muchos lo
llegaron a comparar incluso con la época
más dura del Isis entre ellos el propio
Primer Ministro israelí Benjamin
netanyahu jamás ató quemó y ejecutó a
niños son salvajes jamás Es Isis Y al
igual que las fuerzas de la civilización
se unieron para derrotar al Isis las
fuerzas de la civilización deben apoyar
a Israel para derrotar a jamás desde
entonces la contraofensiva israelí ha
sido tajante ha entrado en gaza y ha
bombardeado cientos y cientos miles de
objetivos la comunidad musulmana mundial
ha calificado esta respuesta militar
como todo un genocidio y ahora la gran
mayoría de analistas temen que esta sea
la excusa perfecta para un llamamiento
masivo a una nueva jihat el ex líder de
jamas por ejemplo ya lo ha hecho pero
tienen las palabras de mesal algo de
relevancia pues seguramente Sí pero
tanta como para calificarlo como un
llamamiento a la jijad internacional
Pues lo más seguro es que no por una
simple razón alcaeda y elisis los
máximos representantes del yihadismo
global aman tanto a jamás como un
musulmán al jamón es decir absolutamente
nada Sí a ver es cierto tanto jamás como
alqaeda y el Isis comparten ciertos
puntos comunes su odio a Israel su
percepción del país hebreo como una
marioneta de occidente o el fomento de
la violencia contra la comunidad judía
son sin ir más lejos alguno de ellos
pero la realidad es que la relación
entre ellos es más bien
[Música]
pésima desde que jamás participara en
las elecciones al consejo legislativo de
Palestina en el año 2006 tanto alcaeda
como el Isis han criticado duramente a
la organización Palestina los dos
máximos exponentes del yihadismo global
condenaron su participación en un
proceso democrático que ambos califican
de impuro además la lentitud y el
gradualismo de jamás a la hora de
imponer la sharía en gaza ha sido otra
importante fuente de críticas por parte
de los otros dos grupos terroristas
luego el acercamiento de jamás a Irán y
a hezbolá tampoco ha ayudado
especialmente a la hora de reconstruir
sus vínculos de hecho el Isis es
especialmente duro con jamás al que
critica Por no tener como objetivo claro
el establecimiento de un estado islámico
mundial sino a dar prioridad a la
liberalización de Palestina sin embargo
alcaeda ha diferenciado entre el brazo
político de jamás al que condena
fuertemente y su brazo militarizado las
brigadas kassam al que sí
[Música]
apoy con una relación tan erosionada por
mucho que desde jamás se pueda llamar a
una ljad global si sus dos principales
exponentes no le secundan Pues es
improbable que esta tenga lugar entonces
La pregunta es han llamado tanto alcaeda
como el Isis a una jihad global pues no
de manera completa pero poco les ha
faltado Y es que veréis tras el atentado
de jamás alcaeda aplaudió la acción y
aprovechó para hacer un llamamiento al
ataque de objetivos americanos en
Oriente medio en especial en las
principales ciudades de los países que
firmaron los acuerdos de Abraham el is
por su parte no felicitó en ningún
momento a jamás y siguió
criticándome chó para publicar una lista
de objetivos judíos a perseguir en
cualquier parte del mundo ojo con esto
sea como sea tanto si esto es una
llamada al aijaz global como si no lo es
sí que es una llamada a la violencia
dirigida Y sabéis qué ya ha tenido y
está teniendo
repercusiones Egipto un policía mata a
tiros a dos turistas israelíes y a un
guía
egipcio un empleado de la embajada
israelí en China ha sido apu sealado
detenido un sospechoso
extranjero un hombre armado mata a dos
ciudadanos suecos en pleno centro de
Bruselas y es abatido por la policía son
tan solo tres ejemplos Pero por
desgracia las noticias de actos
antisemitas y de ataques terroristas
parecen estar en oe y como no podía ser
de otra forma también han llegado a la
vieja Europa y ojo porque la cuestión es
que el problema en Europa puede llegar a
ser incluso mayor que en el resto de
occidente Por qué pues prestad mucha
atención
yihadismo
escurridizo desde la reactivación
intensa del conflicto entre Israel y
Palestina los atentados radicales
islamistas casi que han vuelto a acopar
un espacio semanal en las noticias
internacionales los casos de Egipto y de
China fueron de los primeros pero Europa
por desgracia no se ha quedado atrás un
profesor muerto y dos heridos en un
apuñalamiento en una escuela del norte
de Francia tiroteo en Bruselas Europa
conmocionada tras la muerte a tiros de
dos
suecos Alemania detiene a un islamista
que planeaba un atentado terrorista
contra Israel se ha detenido a un hombre
condenado anteriormente por ser miembro
del llamado estado islámico según la
fiscalía presuntamente planeaba llevar a
cabo un atentado de motivación islamista
contra una manifestación Pro israelí
todos ellos dijeron actuar En nombre del
Isis e incluso uno de ellos había tenido
ya fuertes vínculos con este grupo
terrorista no obstante estos casos nos
muestran algo mucho pero que mucho más
importante la nueva cara del terrorismo
jihadista que lleva dominando Europa
desde el surgimiento del Isis os estamos
hablando de la figura del Lobo
[Música]
solitario el Lobo solitario que es un
individuo que se ha radicalizado de
manera Autónoma y que ha tenido un
contacto limitado o incluso nulo con
células terroristas ha sido el principal
responsable de los ataques terroristas
en Europa por ejemplo entre 2014 y 2017
los años de la oleada jihadista en el
Continente el 85 por de todos los
atentados fueron perpetrados
precisamente por l o solitarios Pues
bien hoy estos terroristas son con mucha
diferencia la mayor amenaza por dos
razones en primer lugar porque su
contacto con células terroristas es a
veces nulo y por lo tanto hace mucho más
difícil su detección y segundo porque
pueden atacar con herramientas normales
que no levantan sospechas Como por
ejemplo cuchillos sin duda son un
auténtico quebradero de cabeza para las
agencias de seguridad Nacional de todo
occidente amigos este nuevo actor
potencialmente más peligroso incluso que
las células terroristas que atentaron en
Europa a principios de siglo no es
ninguna pero que ninguna broma para que
os hagáis una idea de cómo están las
cosas tened presente que hoy tan solo
las fuerzas de seguridad de España están
siguiendo el rastro de al menos 300
potenciales lobos solitarios una
barbaridad precisamente por eso las
agencias de inteligencia Y de seguridad
de Europa llevan ya tiempo intentando
luchar contra este fenómeno en uno de
los espacios que más lobos solitarios ha
generado las redes sociales y el espacio
virtual Y es que veréis si bien el
califato de elisis se desvaneció
físicamente casi por completo su
presencia virtual no ha decaído en
ningún un momento de hecho durante las
cuarentenas en la primera ola de la
covid-19 su presencia se fortaleció aún
más y con ello el reclutamiento online
esto es especialmente preocupante ya que
a menudo Los Lobos solitarios aprenden a
montar artefactos explosivos con
diferentes reclutadores y entrenadores
virtuales este fue por ejemplo el caso
del terrorista de Manchester en 2017 por
otro lado la propaganda online del
yihadismo Aunque simple Se ha probado
tremendamente efectiva explotando las
confusiones de identidad de muchos
inmigrantes de segunda generación en los
países europeos e instalando un
sentimiento de victimismo ante las
supuestas agresiones de occidente y sus
sociedades los reclutadores del
yihadismo global han ido consiguiendo
cada vez más adeptos es decir
potenciales
terroristas sin embargo muchos analistas
señalan a otro lugar como un potencial
nido de jihadistas las cárceles de hecho
Medina muche responsable de la estado
contra el museo judío de Bélgica en 2014
se radicalizó durante su condena de
prisión de 5 años por robo y lógicamente
esto tiene una explicación Y es que
veréis en las cárceles europeas
encontramos hoy a cientos sin no a miles
de excombatientes del Isis combatientes
que salieron del viejo continente para
luchar en Irak y Siria no olvidemos que
más de 6,000 ciudadanos europeos se
fueron para allá Pues bien los analistas
y las agencias de seguridad nacionales
temen que estos estén radicalizando a
otros presos en las cárceles haciendo de
esta forma que las cárceles se
conviertan en potenciales universidades
jihadistas y por si fuera poco tamb
también se está alertando de la
excarcelación de excombatientes europeos
del
ISIS y es que muchos ya han cumplido con
sus penas de esta forma cuando salen de
prisión pues no está claro si todavía
están o no radicalizados así que
queridos amigos de visual politic ya lo
veis Europa parece estar a punto de
embarcarse en una nueva oleada de
terrorismo jihadista el riesgo está
sobre la mesa la comunidad musulmana
global está que arde y el mensaje
radical expandido por alcaeda y el Isis
ya calado en una parte minoritaria pero
absolutamente problemática de esta
unidad Europa prevaleció durante la
primera ola de terrorismo jihadista de
hace menos de una década pero hoy Los
Lobos solitarios pueden ponerla en jacke
la mayor versatilidad de estos hace que
la posible nueva oada jihadista sea más
difícil de frenar lo que obliga a las
agencias de inteligencia Y de seguridad
nacionales a reconfigurar sus
estrategias antiterroristas aquí en
visual politic como siempre estaremos
muy atentos a todo lo que ocurra pero
por ahora el turno es para ti crees que
finalmente llegará una nueva oleada diad
esta Europa cómo piensas que se podría
afrontar el reto de Los Lobos solitarios
ves posible que la nueva oleada llegue a
Estados Unidos pod dejarnos como siempre
vuestras respuestas en los comentarios y
así abrir el debate y no olvidéis que
aquí en visual politics sacamos
contenidos nuevos Todas las semanas así
que no se os pasé suscribiros si es que
todavía no lo habéis hecho una vez más
Muchas gracias por estar ahí un saludo y
hasta la
[Música]
próxima